من خلفه مبانا مدمره وبيده رايه يقول انها
العلم الروسي هذا المقطع المصور نشره رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه في وقت متاخرا من
ليل الاحد على حسابه في تيليجرام ليؤكد ان
مدينه بخموت اصبحت تحت السيطره الروسيه
بالمعنى القانوني على حد وصفه
تمت السيطره على بخموت قاده الوحدات التي
انتزعت البلديه والمركز سيرفعون هذا
العالم هذه الشركه العسكريه الخاصه وهؤلاء
الرجال الذين اخذوا بخموت بالمعنى
القانوني اصبحت لنا
القوات الاوكرانيه تراجعت الى الاجزاء
الغربيه من المدينه الا ان هيئه الاركان
العامه الاوكرانيه اكدت فجر الاثنين ان
قواتها ما زالت تقاوم لا يوقف العدو
هجماته على بخموت محاولا السيطره عليها
بشكل كامل وقد صدى جنودنا اكثر من عشرين
هجوما للعدو
الرئيس الاوكراني في وقت سابق من يوم
الاحد بصعوبه الوضع الميداني الشكر
لجنودنا الذين يقاتلون بالقرب من ابديفكا
ومارينكا وبحمود ولا سيما محمود حيث الوضع
ملتهب اليوم المدينه التي كان عدد سكانها
يبلغ 70 الف نسمه قبل الحرب دمرت المعارك
العنيفه التي دارت على ارضها وصفت بانها
الاطول امدا في الحرب الاوكرانيه وتسببت
بخسائر فادحه لكلا الجانبين واصبحت
المدينه رمزا للصراع من اجل السيطره على
منطقه دومباس الصناعيه
وتعتقد اوكرانيا ان معركه بخمول ضروريه
لاحتواء تقدم القوات الروسيه على الجبهه
الشرقيه باكملها الا ان محللين عسكريين لا
يولون اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره لهذه
المدينه